Salut à tous! Aujourd'hui nous sommes samedi, c'est le jour du Master class.
Je vous l'avais annoncé la semaine dernière,
aujourd'hui on voit comment réussir ses examens.
En tout cas c'est une première partie, j'en ferai surement d'autres sur ce sujet là,
et aujourd'hui on va se concentrer exclusivement sur les révisions :
la manière d'apprendre et la manière de réviser.
On va apprendre à apprendre.
On va parler d'une méthode très intéressante pour ça : les cartes heuristiques,
que vous connaissez peut-être sous le nom de "Mind Map".
C'est un concept, au départ, qui a été pensé par Aristote, et en 1960, Tony Buzan (on en a déjà parlé dans ces vidéos),
a développé tout un concept autour de ça.
L'idée même des Mind Map est très simple :
c'est d'exploiter les chemins amnésiques entre 2 neurones.
Quand 2 neurones se connectent à l'aide d'une idée, ils font un espèce de sentier, on appelle ça une "trace mnésique".
Pour vous donner une image, c'est comme si vous alliez dans une forêt où il n'y a pas de chemin
et que vous marchez tout droit. Ca va commencer à créer un petit chemin parce que vous allez pousser des branches,
vous allez peut-être casser un peu de feuillage : vous allez créer un petit sentier.
Ca va être un peu dur la première fois, mais plus vous allez prendre ce chemin, plus le sentier sera dégagé et accessible,
mais au bout de X passages ce sera devenu complètement dégagé et vous pourrez marcher tranquillement par ce chemin là dans la forêt.
C'est exactement ce qu'il se passe avec la trace mnésique.
La première fois le lien à faire entre les 2 neurones va être compliqué, au tout départ.
Mais plus vous allez utiliser ce chemin là, en fait plus vous allez réviser, plus vous allez faire appel à ce lien là,
plus il va se renforcer et à la fin il sera quasiment automatique.
Mais le Mind Map c'est encore plus malin que ça, ça utilise également le gestalt,
c'est la tendance qu'a notre cerveau à compléter les choses.
Si je vous dit "sel", vous pensez quasiment instantanément à "poivre",
parce que le chemin qui a été lié est fort entre les 2, et le cerveau a envie d'anticiper et de compléter.
Votre chemin neuronal fait en sorte de compléter à l'avance, d'anticiper les informations dont vous avez besoin
et donc vous les sert comme ça sur un plateau.
C'est principalement grâce à ces deux choses là que le Mind Map est un outil très puissant pour les révisions et donc pour réussir ses examens.
Si vous avez jamais vu ou que vous connaissiez pas le nom, je vais vous en faire voir quelques uns.
C'est une espèce d'outil holistique et graphique, comme ceci,
je vous en fais passer quelques uns,
qui peut s'appliquer à tout ce qui est cognitif,
donc la mémoire, la créativité : toutes les formes de pensées, quelles qu'elles soient.
Créer un Mind Map, c'est cartographier l'information.
Au lieu de faire de la prise de notes propre, organisée comme on le fait habituellement,
on va la rendre plus graphique, on va la rendre plus nourrissante pour le cerveau.
Vous le savez, je vous le dit souvent, le cerveau aime les images.
Quand vous allez créer vos premiers Mind Map, vous allez placer l'information principale au centre,
en la représentant si possible par une image, ça marche beaucoup mieux,
ça peut être quelque chose que vous prenez de l'ordinateur, quelque chose que vous dessinez,
même si vous dessinez très mal : même moi je suis capable de faire un Mind Map
alors qu'on a vu la qualité de mes dessins l'autre jour...
Et ensuite vous allez placer des ramifications.
Si je devais cartographier avec un Mind Map le Mental Vlog, je mettrais "Mental vlog" en plein milieu,
je mettrais peut-être un cerveau en dessin,
et je ferais une ramification qui partirait vers "explication", une autre vers "Master class",
j'ouvrirais l'information, par exemple à partir de "Master class", une branche qui part sur la mémoire, une branche qui part sur les mathématiques.
Vous allez créer un peu comme un arbre des ramifications
appliqué à des révisions, à de la connaissance, à des choses qu'on doit apprendre pour un examen.
Il est très simple de faire des Mind Map globaux sur toute l'information,
ou de faire des Mind Map spécifiques à chaque chose qu'on doit apprendre soi-même, ça peut marcher pour tout,
même juste pour une fiche littéraire pour un bac de français,
aussi bien que pour des études de médecin.
L'essentiel c'est de combiner les mots, les couleurs et les images.
Le but final c'est que votre cerveau prenne une photo de ça
Donc vous allez le nourrir de toute cette logique d'images, de tout ce que vous y avez mis, de la forme des branches,
de la manière dont vous allez écrire les mots, du relief que vous allez mettre dedans, des images, des couleurs!
Quand vous allez repenser à votre information principale, au thème, à ce que vous avez mis au centre,
l'ensemble va commencer à se redessiner dans votre tête, et chaque élément, chaque gros thème, chaque logique qui va vous revenir,
va faire rappel à toute l'information que vous avez déjà engendrée au départ en l'apprenant.
Et grâce au gestalt, le fait de penser à une partie de la Mind Map va faire que votre cerveau va penser à tout le reste,
il va compléter cette image là.
C'est, selon moi, et je suis pas le seul à le penser,
la meilleure méthode pour apprendre, pour réviser, pour engranger de la connaissance dans le temps
en la répertoriant de manière maline dans son cerveau.
Une fois que vous avez créé un Mind Map, il faut forcément le réviser, il faut le retenir.
C'est extrêmement simple, une fois que vous l'avez créé,
20min après, vous le reprenez, vous le révisez un petit peu, vous le redétaillez, vous le regardez de nouveau.
Vous faites ça également le lendemain.
Une fois que vous l'avez fait le lendemain, vous le reposez et vous le reprenez 7 jours plus tard
Une fois que vous avez fait ça vous le reprenez un mois plus tard,
une fois que vous avez fait ça vous le reprenez 3 mois plus tard,
et une fois que vous avez fait ça vous le reprenez 6 mois plus tard.
A partir de ce moment là, on pourra considérer qu'il est rentré dans la mémoire à long terme et que vous ne l'oublierez plus.
Ça présuppose 2 choses, la première c'est que vous avez lu et compris ou écouté les informations principales
que vous avez traduites ensuite par prise de notes en Mind Map,
et ça présuppose encore une fois que vous avez mis beaucoup de couleurs,
beaucoup de richesse, beaucoup de logique, de VOTRE logique à vous
à l'intérieur de cette carte là.
Quand je parle de relief, c'est aussi bien pour les mots,
par exemple si j'écris "grand" je vais l'écrire vraiment grand, si j'écris "petit" je vais l'écrire vraiment petit.
Ca marche aussi pour le relief que vous allez donner aux branches : les branches principales moi j'ai tendance à les faire beaucoup plus grosses.
C'est très facile à faire, c'est pas long, ça prend pas beaucoup de temps.
Vous avez vu les révisions c'est pareil : 20 min après, 1 jour, 7 jours, 1 mois, 3 mois, 6 mois...
Si vous voulez aller plus loin la-dedans, ce que je vous recommande,
vous pouvez vous procurer un des livres de Tony Buzan. Il en a écrit un avec son frère Barry
qui s'appelle "Dessine-moi l'intelligence", il est très très complet avec des exemples de Mind Map. Tenez je vais vous en faire voir d'ailleurs
Ça c'est un Mind Map pour parvenir à une vie équilibrée,
ça c'en est un sur la créativité,
ça c'en est un d'un cours d'histoire, c'est très intéressant, c'est le début de la Seconde Guerre Mondiale.
Je vous conseille ce livre mais il en existe beaucoup d'autres, d'autres auteurs d'ailleurs!
Peu importe lequel vous choisirez, c'est pas un placement de produit.
Ma seule envie c'est que vous en choisissiez un pour aller un peu plus loin dans l'aventure du Mind Map.
Je pense pas qu'on puisse tout dire en une vidéo, quand bien même c'est un Master Class,
il faudrait presque faire une formation de 2-3h rien que sur ce sujet là...
...comme souvent d'ailleurs dans les Master Class!
N'hésitez pas non plus à le faire découvrir à d'autres personnes, je pense que c'est applicable dans tous les domaines
que ce soit pour faire un discours, pour organiser sa vie, pour organiser son travail, pour apprendre des choses peu importe,
c'est un outil très très précieux.
Et si ce Master class vous a plu il y a aussi un mind map facile pour me le faire savoir c'est de laisser un petit
POUCE EN L'AIR
Je vous mets tous les liens dans la barre d'informations
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir, vous pouvez laisser un petit commentaire!
Passez un bon weekend, bon courage à ceux qui ont des choses à apprendre ou à réviser,
rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain mental vlog,
tchao!